we often hear the claim that the Council
of NAA in 3:25 was the first time that
the books of the New Testament were
decided on and canonized for the first
time or that it was at this point that
the doctrine of the Trinity and you know
Christianity as we know it was quote
unquote made up now neither of these
statements are true and the first one is
especially false in fact the Council of
NAA had nothing to do with which books
were to be included in the Bible that
isn't to say that it wasn't important it
was very important the Council of NAIA
in fact is one of the most important
moments at least starting point to one
of the most important moments in the
history of Christianity uh but there is
so much misinformation and
misunderstanding surrounding this topic
like for example the things I just
mentioned that people think that it was
here that the the Bible was decided on
like was canonized which is simply not
true what the Council of NAA was about
was establishing the Trinity the doct of
the Trinity um you know coming to a kind
of official theological position within
Christianity now that isn't to say that
all of Christianity accepted this
particular Doctrine after NAA in fact
not at all this was a much longer
process but still the council Nia is a
very important starting point for the
formulation of what we you know would
come to know as mainstream or Orthodox
Christianity but the trinity as a basic
idea was already well established by
this time when the council was held what
was disagreed upon was just how the
Divine life functioned especially the
relationship between the father God and
the son identified with Christ as many
know this was very much in response to a
certain intellectual debate that was
raging at that time and particularly
against a specific quotquot heresy known
as
aryanism there is significant
misunderstanding about Aran ISM itself
and the debate that was had around it so
in this episode well time to the
Christmas season I thought we'd discuss
one of the biggest controversies in
early Christianity uh a theological
intellectual debate that would serve or
be the Catalyst
for much of Christianity as we know it
in many
[Applause]
ways the early history of Christianity
is one of the most interesting and yet
misunderstood topics in this entire
field we've spoken about this period and
its complexities in many earlier videos
but it's worth going through some of the
basics the classic Christian retelling
of the events is a confessional one
based on the fact that an Orthodoxy was
established eventually and it thus sees
the events of early Christianity as
simply the process in which the quote
unquote Shu Church defeated a bunch of
heresies from a historical scarly point
of view this version of events canot not
be upheld without significant nuancing
the idea that there was a unified quote
unquote Orthodox Church from the very
beginning from jesus' death and the
apostles and which was safeguarded by a
group of true Christians over the
centuries against a bunch of heresies
that diverged from this true teaching
before Orthodoxy became formly
established with the church councils is
simply not true early Christianity or
the Jesus movement as it is often called
was chaotic and messy there was no
unified church but a whole explosion of
different ideas thinkers and schools of
thought my colleague Andrew Henry from
the channel religion for breakfast
refers to it in one of his videos as a
supernova of Jesus movements or
christianities in the plural in this
early period which I think is a fitting
image various different Christians and
non-Christian followers of Jesus tried
to figure out what Christ's Mission
meant and they all came up with a whole
plethora of different perspectives some
saw Jesus as a human human prophets and
not Divine at all such as the ebionites
others that he was fully Divine and not
human at all which like the gnostics for
example while still others tried to
tackle positions in between some wanted
to still follow the Jewish law others
didn't some even rejected the Old
Testament or Hebrew Bible entirely and
saw the god of the Old Testament as an
evil pseudo deity that had tricked
Humanity into worshiping him namely the
group that came to be known as the
gnostics and for centuries things
remained this way there isn't a
Christianity but various different
christianities Scholars are even
skeptical of the idea that there was
even necessarily schools of thought as
such at least in the earliest period but
a messy exchange of different ideas and
perspectives on all conceivable
topics eventually over the centuries
certain ideas of course became more
popular and widely accepted than others
and certain scriptures also were
increasingly seen as canonical or not
this is why by the time of the Council
of NAA I kind of of Canon was already
present because certain texts such as
the four gospels in the New Testament
were just simply the most popular out of
all these different scriptures that were
going around similarly the theological
tenants of Christianity developed over
the centuries too such as the idea of
the Divine as somehow consisting of
three principles the father Son and Holy
Spirit from a certain perspective one
can argue that such ideas and readings
of scripture were very much in
conversation with the philosophical
traditions that were popular at that
time such as platonism and others which
often had a three-part scheme of higher
realities too just look at platanus and
the neoplatonists they one New Soul
hypothesis for example but that isn't to
say that because these terms and general
ideas were present that the Nan form of
the Trinity as we know it existed in
earlier periods when we read early
church fathers like origin we can surely
see traces of what would become the
trinitarian doctrine at least in some
aspect but to say that origin upheld I
see in Trinity that would be Orthodox in
ler history is simply untenable for
example in other words these ideas
develop over time now that isn't to say
that they aren't necessarily true we're
not making a confessional argument here
that's not our place that's not what
this is for what we're doing is looking
at this from a historical perspective uh
and from that perspective we can see
that these ideas develop or at least
formulated in convers in conversation
with each other different groups and
school schools but also with outside um
thinkers and and schools of thought as
well such as platonism for instance it's
it's a it's a it's an environment where
a lot of stuff is happening
intellectually and we can see that many
of these ideas are formulated and and uh
and sort of emerge in that and through
that environment and this is why Aras
and aryanism are so interesting because
the Aryan controversy as it is often
known comes at a decisive moment in the
formation of the church this is right at
the time when some of those Central
doctrines were being formulated or
standardized and this process would very
much culminate in the great councils
starting with the one in NAA and think
of it this way the Council of NAA
wouldn't have happened if it wasn't for
the Aryan controversy it is because of
this debate that these Christians and
Constantine felt the need to Define what
they actually believed in contrast to
What was seen as heresy or what would
become seen as heresy as is often the
case self identity is based on
identifying oneself in distinction to
the other in this case the arens but
this also becomes one of our main
obstacles in studying Aras and the arens
who was Aras and what did he and his
followers maybe sympathizers actually
believe well the problem is that the
vast majority of our sources come from
what would become the Orthodox in other
words the enemies of Aras and this
carries with it the usual problems that
we often find Aras and his ideas are
identified as the extreme other as the
kind of arch heretic demonically
inspired misleader of the people as such
these sources aren't always that
concerned with giving a fair or
comprehensive representation of what his
actual Doctrine was but based on careful
reading of these sources as well as some
less problematic ones we can try to
understand more properly the origins of
this controversy and what it was all
about Aras seems to have been from Libya
originally born sometime before the year
280 he dedicated most of his life to
theological and intellectual Pursuits
and stories say that he studied in
Antioch under the teacher Lucian which
many considered to be a key source for
his own doctrines he later moved to
Alexandria in Egypt though a city which
he would be associated with for the rest
of his life this place was a key Center
for Christianity at that time and for a
lot of other activities too Alexandria
in the first few centuries ad is one of
the most interesting places in history
where so much is happening at the same
time in any case Aries became a quite
prominent presor and priest in one of
the areas of the city but controversies
erupted and his own theological ideas
seems to have created tension with other
Christian leaders in the city including
and perhaps especially the Bishops Peter
Alexander and eventually
atius and from around the year 318 the
Aryan controversy properly sort of
started and we can follow this train of
events through number of letters and
writings written both by Aras and his
supporters and by his critics such as
Alexander the the bishop of Alexandria
and even the emperor Constantine himself
during this controversy Aras was
excommunicated from Alexandria he found
refuge and support in Palestine and
Syria and continue to argue for his case
through discourses with the clergy in
Egypt AR seems to have been very
charismatic and popular among a wide
range of people and perhaps because of
this because he had so many supporters
around you know the the med median
region he seems to have at one point
returned to Alexandria but by that point
the church in that city was basically in
a state of chaos and unrest for the
emperor Constantine who had just made
Christianity a legal religion in the
Roman Empire this wasn't a good look a
divided church was a liability to the
Empire in many ways and so he made the
decision that would reverberate
throughout history by calling the
Council of NAA in 325 to solve this
controversy and once and for all Det
determine what the Creed of Orthodox
Christianity was to be but what was this
controversy all about what were these
doctrines and ideas of Aras and his
sympathizers that would be discussed in
this Council and which were so
controversial at this time well first of
all we should be careful not to see this
as some kind of unique school of thought
founded by Aras himself he did become a
figurehead of sorts during the
controversy for sure due precisely to
the controversy in Alexander itself
which he was part of but Aras was only
one figure that represented a general
attitude towards christology at that
time and there were many others who
supported Aras thus being deemed Aryans
at that time such as eusebius of
nicomedia and eus of cesaria these and
later supporters all stood behind Aras
not as some kind of absolute Authority
or leader but simply on the basis of his
Orthodoxy that he believed in a
legitimate version of what the Divine is
so we should be careful to not see him
as some sort of leader of a school of
thought but that the arens that became
known as the arens those who supported
him simply supported his Orthodoxy they
believed that Aras was an orthodox
Christians his beliefs fitted into uh
right belief within the Christian fault
so to say Rowan Williams writes quote
arianism as a coherent system founded by
a single great figur and sustained by
his disciples is a fantasy more exactly
a fantasy based on the polemic of nyine
writers above all
athanas some anti- nyin may in the early
days have been happy with the name of
arens as a designation of their
theological preferences not their
ecclesiastical Allegiance but it is most
unlikely that they would have been
content with such a name for long after
NAA arianism was neither a church nor a
connection in its own eyes Aryans
thought of themselves naturally enough
as Catholics or more accurately the very
wide spectrum of non-n belever
thought of themselves as mainstream
Christians and regarded athanasius and
his allies as isolated extremists though
increasingly they also looked on the
more aggressive antiy scenes Aus yomious
and the like as no less alien to the
mainstream of Catholic tradition in fact
the later quote unquote Aryans and
what's often known as Neo Arians could
significantly disagree and adjust the
ideas of Aras in different ways even
though they remain consistent in some
basic features and especially in
contrast to the nyine formulations of
the Trinity so again what are these
foundations of so-called
arianism as we said the debate at this
time and which was had at the council uh
was essentially one about the nature of
the Divine and the nature of the Trinity
particularly what is the relationship
between the Son and the father so the
son as in Jesus Christ and God the
Father what is the nature of their
relationship um and already we should
dispel some common misconceptions about
this um Aryans did not believe that
Jesus was a Hu just simply a human being
U similar to what Muslims believe that
Jesus was just a human Prophet or
something like that that was not what
this debate was about everyone involved
agreed that that Jesus was divine that
Jesus was God in some way um but the
question was in what way was he God God
or rather if he's
Divine how is he Divine in relationship
to to the father to God the Father we
might be able to perhaps um compare this
to another early debate in in or as
should say a debate in early Islam in
Islamic theology uh about the nature of
the Quran so there was this famous
debate between the which is a sort of
theological school and early theological
School in Islam and what
is very broadly sometimes refer to as
the
traditionalists um and the M believe
that the Quran was created whereas the
traditionalist believe that it was
uncreated and here it was never a
question of whether you know the Quran
was the literal word of God they all
agreed that the Quran was the word of
God uh what was the question was whether
did God create the Quran as his speech
at a particular
time just as he creates other things in
the world or is the Quran the sort of
uncreated Eternal speech of God that
exists with God before creation so in
many ways this is a very similar kind of
theological debate uh that is had here
with Jesus they all agree that Jesus is
divine but in what way is he Divine
there's there's sort of different levels
of of how much the sun is identified
with with God the Father the Bible seems
to say that the father begets the son
that he's born from the father in some
way this to Aras and his supporters
seemed to indicate that the son comes
about after the father he comes from the
father thus not being completely of the
same substance as the father they're not
the same thing in other words the son
Jesus is subordinate to the father he
comes from the father and thus stands on
a level slightly under him rather than
being of the exact same Essence so to
say to the arens to say that the father
and the son as well as the Holy Spirit
are of the same Essence homo Usos
compromise the idea of the unity of God
too much instead that which is begotten
from the father must come after the
father not in a temporal sense of being
created at a later date since Aries
seems to argue that the son is somehow
co-eternal with the father at least in
some sense at least existing before
creation so he doesn't come after the
father temporally but
ontologically there are a few s sources
that are often directly attributed to
Aras himself the first is a confession
of Faith written to Alexander of
Alexandria the bishop that he had a sort
of constant beef with secondly there is
a letter written to eusebius of
nicomedia one of his supporters and
thirdly there is a confession submitted
by Aras to the emperor Constantine
himself there is also a text referred to
as the Thalia which is often seen as the
most important source for the teachings
of Aras and exist only in secondhand
mentions and fragments but in his
confessions to Constantine where he is
trying to argue for his own Orthodoxy he
says very clearly that the son is quote
produced by the father before all ages
and that all things are made through
this son this should significantly
Nuance what the Aran teaching actually
was or perhaps rather what it was not it
was not a denial of Christ Divinity as
is clearly seen here in the letter Aras
states that he believes in the Trinity
and that trinitarianism is indeed based
on scripture he burs belief in the three
hypotheses of the Divine Father Son and
Holy Spirit this might be surprising to
some but it shouldn't be Aras as we can
see simply believe that the relationship
between the persons of the Trinity had a
different relationship than the nyine
group did although aside from this issue
we can of course find other ways in
which he diverges from would be
Orthodoxy too above all Aries wanted to
safeguard God's uniqueness and
timelessness if the Sun is of the same
essence or or substance as the father as
the nyine Creed holds that seems to
compromise this nature of God because a
son comes from a father he's begotten
from the father th there is change in
the godhead so what then is the point of
the begetting and the father son
relationship that's mentioned in the
bible if that relationship doesn't mean
what it does the one comes from the
other being created by it and thus
standing below it in some way if the son
is identical to the father in that way
that seems to compromise his
timelessness because the son comes from
the father at some point you could say
although this point is before creation
as we saw in the Thalia the ideas of
Aras are presented in relatively clear
ways he says that quote so God himself
is inexpressible to all beings he alone
has none equal to him or like him none
of like Glory we call him unbegotten on
account of the one who by nature is
begotten we sing his Praises as without
beginning because of the one who has a
beginning we worship him as Eternal
because of him who was born in the order
of time the one without beginning
established the son as the beginning of
all creatures and having fathered such a
one he bore him as a son for himself he
the son possesses nothing proper to God
in the real sense of propriety for he is
not equal to God nor yet is he of the
same substance hum oos pretty clear
statement against some of the key
features of the Nyan Creed including the
idea of who
Moos the son is not of the same Essence
as the Father the Son is created by the
father he is a creature not in the sense
of creatures here on Earth but as
something created not part of the
essence of the pure Eternal godhead he
is and this is the key term in arianism
subordinate to the father these ideas
become even more clear later on in this
text quote the father is other than the
son in substance because he is without
beginning the father that is you should
understand that the monad always was but
the diad was not before it came to be at
once then you see that the father is God
even when the son does not exist so the
son not existing eternally since he came
into being by the father's will is God
the only begotten and he maybe the holy
spirit is different from both for sure
the son is special among creation even
Divine or God in some way as the text
seem to suggest he is the first thing
created the word from which all other
things are created but he has no power
other than that given to him by the
father he is again subordinate to the
father this is basically the gist of
aras's theology there's of course a lot
more nuance and other details that we
could discuss but that's probably beyond
the scope of this episode so that's
that's that's the basic idea that is
what he believed and that is at least
some version of that is what many of his
sympath iers or followers believe the
Aryans uh and which was so controversial
and um rejected by the Nan Creed and
eventually became rejected by mainstream
Christianity as a whole the Council of
NAA instead came up with the so-called
Nan Creed which states that the father
and son are humo OS they are of the same
substance or the same Essence which is
something that Aras and his followers
here project outright they say this is
they believe that that was heresy right
but the nyine Creed established this as
as as the correct Creed so to say and
Aras wasn't actually present at the at
the Council of NAA however some of his
supporters were like the the previously
mentioned uh UC by the the two
euses um that were seen as as arens but
even though the nine creed was
established during this Council that did
not mean that that became just became
accepted by everyone in fact the story
about this is is a lot more messy the
whole nyine formulation kind of falls
apart right after the council takes
place for various reasons and so the
story is not over yet in fact at first
the council didn't have much of an
impact at all some supporters of Aras
and Aras himself were indeed exiled but
eventually with new controversies in the
Church of Alexandria their case was
basically reopened arus was invited to
return and defend his case in
Constantinople and it seems that in the
end he was considered Orthodox once
again and was to be given communion
again but very dramatically he died in
Constantinople in 336 some say the very
day before he was to be reinstated into
the church although the stories do kind
of diverge here we don't know exactly
what happened or when it happened he
might have already been re reins stated
like accepted back into the into the
church again before he died we simply
don't know although many of his enemies
will of course use this particular story
that he died the day before as a kind of
sign that God said like no you don't
right that that was a sign of his of his
heresy in a certain sense so this
significantly Alters our common image of
the situation but it's important to
remember the Council of NAA didn't
really decide anything quickly
afterwards it was abandoned and many
Emperors turned to arianism Future
councils such as the Council of Ty in
335 even accepted arianism as the
official Creed it wasn't really until
the Council of Constantinople in 381
that a granted a modified version of the
nyine Creed kind of finally in
officially became the Orthodox position
so things are more complicated than we
like to imagine the Creed of Aras and
the quote unquote Arians or more
accurately the people that simply didn't
agree with the Nan formulation of
Christian theology who in themselves
could be varied in their doctrines was
seen as legitimate by many people and
for a long period of time indeed looking
at the earlier history of the church
such theologies are kind of the norm if
we're being honest some of the earliest
theologians and philosophers of
Christianity such as Clement of
Alexandria and origin all seem to hold a
kind of subordination theology just like
Aras did we should also point out once
again that the whole category of
arianism is also somewhat problematic
since he eventually became seen as the
arch heretic the term Aran was used to
denote basically anyone that disagreed
with the Nan Creed even though they
could be quite different from each other
we even sometimes refer to the so-called
Neo Aran as a continuation of this
tradition in the later 4th
Century the discussions continue to rage
over the century and the Aryan position
was also modified and changed in
different ways so even though we did go
through the Creed of Aries in particular
before these formulations are not
necessarily upheld by all other quot
unod Aran especially in later periods
instead what unifies this group is the
general rejection of the hum usia
formulation at NAA and instead the
affirmation of the subordination of the
son to the father in The Divine the
Divine Life s to say we could of course
continue this discussion for a long time
um I am not a Christian Theologian and
neither am I necessarily even an expert
on Christian theology so I have in no
way done proper Justice to these topics
and all the intricacies of this topic
but I hope at least they given you a
more nuanced understanding of this early
controversy and perhaps disp some
misconceptions and common um ways that
people misrepresent this topic and and
subject often online on social media and
so on um there is just so much
misinformation about arianism about the
Council of NAA in particular the council
NAA like one of again one of the most
popular things that we hear is that the
Council of NAA decided on the New
Testament cannon that that is when the
books of the New Testament and the the
Bible were decided on and before that
there were no there was nothing of the
sort this is simply not true this
Council n had nothing to do with this
neither did the Council of NAA come up
with the Trinity the idea of the Trinity
and its basic Futures existed before
that but there were different as we see
different perspectives on what the
relationship within that Trinity was and
that isn't to say that everyone believed
in a trinity of course they didn't the
gnostics don't have the Trinity for
example but but many Christians already
had that kind of idea and the Council of
NAIA it only sort of formulates that
into what would eventually become the
Orthodox position on the Trinity um the
Orthodox way of looking at the trinity
in a sort of theological uh
philosophical way and even then the
council isah was not the decisive point
when that became Orthodoxy instead it
was the starting point of a of a of a of
a process that continued for the rest of
the 4th century and even arguably even
Beyond the 4th Century before it became
firmly established as the Orthodoxy as
the Orthodox prision so things are
significantly more complicated and
Nuance than we are often led to believe
in this whole discussion we find the
fastening ideas of Aras and the
so-called Aryans or again perhaps more
accurately the anti- nyine Christians
whose doctrines are similarly
misrepresented by Christians and
non-christians alike hopefully this
episode has in some way dispelled some
of those misunderstandings and giving
you a better overview of the formation
and development of Christianity as we
know it I hope you have a good holiday
season happy holidays everyone and I'll
see you next
[Music]
time